[音楽]
me
やべ
体が怠い
[音楽]
プーペ
いっ
[音楽]
3砂など3文
そんなきつがないんですけど今日は羽生の社長で体が怠いの土が入った鼻水が止まらず
しません
対2が悪いですなんでこの嬉しそうなのが範囲というわけでまだ微熱なんですけどの
非常に体がかったるくてまずげなく風でございます肇社長です考えられる原因は二つ
ちょっと前に月が his をに急がスケベアメリカなる唐櫃
髪の色ですほんとずっと図鑑だけこの色だったんですけど
非常にばれるんですよ動画見てないような人に揉むんか見られてこのいるちょっと
恥ずかしくなってきたのでちょっと今日はこんなシスちょっと髪の毛だけ染めさせて
下さいお願いします
もう関係だけ覚める動画です今日はそもそもこの後ほぼ見てるならそうそうこの髪の毛
に色が入るのかどうかという
問題もありますでだったら大失敗ですねこの一凶ちょっと本当に混ぜな方でちょっと
体調が悪いので何そのご報告とハミを気を治しますと動画でございますとこの後東京
行かなきゃいけないんで行く前になんとかという時だけでも戻して少しでも体調が良く
なればと思っております
もうくれずまず前に何た集ちっていうのはなんか12月はイベントも含めてどんなこと
にちょっと頑張れたのでちょっとツケが回ってきたというかというとこちら
黒髪戻す帽黒でいいでしょうこの慰労た不納付には黒しかないと思ったんで2ね今回は
髪の毛を黒でしていきます
いき落ち着こ池体調も落ち着き対し管理餅つきたいという意味でちょっと黒にしますね
いませんちょっと挙動がやろうと思ったんですけど
いきなり次から髪の毛黒いとみんなもビックリすると思うんで髪の毛の色だけ変えさ
んってください
よそれな網の下だけはなんとするもの赤でもにあると思ったんですけどこっちもいいの
が寝湯妙だったねまあでもイベントでされ愚行いうちょっとて県で衝撃を与えられたの
が嬉しかったんですけどやっぱきちゃうよこの色は
おおーー
もうくらいひょっとしてもうクラクラもうくらいでクルクックがー
うーんあれ染まらないこれひょっとして今4ヶ月過ぎたどうなんだろう
ちょっと洗い落としてみないと分からないですね1回洗い落としてきますでは
はいという意味で無事真っ黒になりましたいいんじゃないですかもう完璧に色の違いが
うわぁ
微妙に違う全然違うじゃないかパッと違和感ないんですけども近く打ったら完全にろ
違う
ヤバイとこれは鼻水大丈夫多分わからないと思うけどやっぱりここら辺でちゃんと
分かるわけはこっちが青でこっちがあっああ
じゃパイぞこれは自然に後は落ちていくと思うんで多分大丈夫だと思います多少マシに
なった分種+演説も下がったしは
[音楽]
hey
me
[音楽]
バッハ
多分
今歯が痛いから今肌痛くてご飯食べれないっていうのもあるしいろんなのが重なって
非常に体調のフォーメーションのナビです
まぁちょっと冬なので皆さんもぜひ風火をつけてください
早く治しますじゃあまた